it is an incredible experience to see
the details of the earth from that
vantage point and to see the earth is
uniquely suited for life I think I've
been on orbit with over 50 different
people if you count them all up to the
the the very unique views of what you
might see in the earth two major
milestones in the Assembly of the space
station and seeing a major
accomplishment in those milestones
during the assembly on the shuttle
flight it was 10 days long so it happens
very quick and and it's very difficult
in a unique experience like that for a
relatively short time to take in the
details so if you wanted to capture the
memories you needed to do it through
photography and video
well I've always loved the parks I grew
up even as a kid I can remember back as
early as four years old my father taken
us on family trips to some of the parks
this year I learned that was the
centennial of the Park Service so what a
great theme to try to capture from that
vantage point Mars has been envisioned
as a goal for decades are we going to go
to Mars how soon are we going to go it
really depends
I believe my personal opinion is that
depends upon the geopolitical situation
in the future that drives potential
international partnerships or
competition among nations
it's just a number it's not that
significant to me so if Peggy
for example exceeds the whatever number
of days I have 537 I guess great good
for her